wieder auf reisen die meisten grenzen in
europa sind seit heute offen viele
reisewarnungen aufgehoben
urlaub auf probe die ersten deutschen
test touristen landen auf mallorca und
unter beobachtung der verfassungsschutz
erklärt die afg in brandenburg zum
verdachtsfall die nachrichten nicht erst
heute mit christian sievers sohn amt in
allen die welt an diesem montag schön
dass sie mit dabei sind mit dabei auch
wieder katja stresow mit dem sport ja
schön wieder da zu sein schien genannt
europa ist wieder offen reisen zumindest
in die meisten eu-länder das geht wieder
das auswärtige abend hat die
entsprechende warnung aufgehoben
vieles blieb da ja in den letzten
monaten auf der strecke der städte trip
ins nachbarland die wandertour in die
alpen oder der badeurlaub am mittelmeer
nun ist die reisefreiheit in große teile
der eu zurück und sie wird auch schon
genutzt susanne freitag und dominik
löschmeister es ist schon etwas mehr los
als die letzten wochen am frankfurter
flughafen viele sind froh wieder ins
europäische ausland fliegen zu können
es geht nach italien kroatien oder
griechenland ja wir freuen uns total
haben eigentlich gar keine angst wir
sind in einem kleinen boutique hotel die
haben nur sechs zimmer nach dem ganzen
druck dauer nach den ganzen wochen kommt
daheim sitzen haben auch wir es einfach
mal wieder in die sonne und abschalten
im gesamten terminal bereich und dem
flugzeug gilt masken pflicht am
flughafen gibt es desinfektionsmittel
und hinweise zum abstandhalten fliegen
in der korona pandemie seien nicht
unsicherer als zuvor betonen die
fluggesellschaften die luft selber im
flugzeug ist so rein wie in einem
operationssaal sie wird alle drei
minuten ausgetauscht und durch
sogenannte hepa filter komplett
gereinigt
dass die airlines die flugzeuge aus
kostengründen voll besetzen wollen diese
entscheidung ist zumindest umstritten
für 27 europäische staaten hob die
bundesregierung ihre reisewarnung auf
für mehr als 160 länder außerhalb der eu
bleibt sie aber bis ende august bestehen
wir sind überall in europa besser
vorbereitet aber das ist noch lange
nicht vorbei und jeder der glaubt man
könnte ein sommerurlaub erleben wie man
ihn aus der vergangenheit kennt der wird
sich im sommer wundern die reisefreiheit
kehrt zurück in europa vor allem für die
grenzregionen ein wichtiger schritt
deutsche und franzosen treffen sich
heute morgen auf der brücke der
freundschaft zwischen dem saarland und
lothringen die rund dreimonatige
grenzschließung eine bewährungsprobe für
die deutsch französische freundschaft
meine persönliche meinung ist dass in
dieser zeit die arbeit von 50 euro vorne
dran innerhalb weniger stunden zerstört
wurde zerstört und hat auch nachhaltig
bis letzte woche war jessica beaver
grenzgängerin in deutschland jetzt wo
die grenze öffnet hat der deutsche
arbeitgeber gekündigt wirtschaftskrise
im grenzgebiet
ich denke dass es für deutschland und
frankreich jetzt sehr schwer wird ich
nehme das deutschland nicht übel
es wird vielen demnächst so gehen wie
mir trotz dieser bunten die jetzt offen
sind hoffe ich dass die
deutsch-französische freundschaft noch
stärker wird
deutsche und franzosen feiern die
wiedererlangte freiheit auch an der
grenze zu dänemark fallen die korona
schlagbäume reisen in europa ist wieder
möglich
wichtiges urlaubsziel für die deutschen
ist mallorca
obwohl spaniens grenzen noch zu sind
dürften heute die ersten deutschen
touristen auf die insel das ganze ist
ein pilotprojekt und reisebegleiter sind
die korona sicherheitsmaßnahmen masken
pflicht und hygieneregeln im hotel
es ist spaniens test ob und wie
massentourismus in corona zeit möglich
ist christel haas das sind die ersten
deutschen touristen auf dem weg nach
mallorca
der flieger voll besetzt maske ist
pflicht sicherheitsabstand aber
unmöglich
empfangen werden sie von wärmekameras
sie die temperatur messen und vielen
journalisten
auch daniel vogt und masse live holz
saßen in dem flugzeug angst haben sie
keine mit den persönlichen daten und
dann stehen die beiden vor ihrem hotel
ein bisschen überrascht so einen empfang
hatten sie nicht erwartet
für die hotelmitarbeiter sind die
touristen ein segen
super also deutsche urlauber als
testpersonen in sachen tourismus in
corona zeiten
es ist der lackmustest für die balearen
die regierung ist zuversichtlich weil
wir die ersten waren die alles schließen
mussten können wir jetzt die ersten sein
die wieder öffnen
die balearen sind sicher natürlich
gelten überall strikte sicherheitsregeln
auch am strand sind zwei meter abstand
vorgeschrieben
abgetrennte areale gibt es aber nicht
und auch keine kontrollen die behörden
setzten auf das
verantwortungsbewusstsein ihrer gäste
und doch ist vieles anders
einmal trinken mit mehrere mann der ihn
fällt das wissen wir alle
gar keine frage nichtsdestotrotz wir
machen das beste draus und das ist nicht
so schwer so leer waren die strände von
mallorca nämlich schon lange nicht mehr
urlaub ist also einiges anders als
früher was reisende ins ausland jetzt
beachten sollten welche regeln und
empfehlungen in den verschiedenen
ländern gelten
all das haben wir in der zdf- heute- app
zusammengestellt und jetzt ein blick auf
die aktuellen corona zahlen in
deutschland da ist die zahl der
neuinfektionen weiter gesunken
im durchschnitt der vergangenen sieben
tage haben sich täglich 250 menschen neu
angesteckt seit ausbruch der pandemie
hat die johns hopkins universität fast
188 1000 infizierte gezählt davon gelten
fast 173.000 als genesen 8804 menschen
sind in verbindung mit 19 gestorben
in der chinesischen hauptstadt peking
wurden seit gestern 36 neuinfektionen
registriert die sorge vor einem neuen
größeren ausbruch wächst
die behörden schlossen einen weiteren
großmarkt und riegelten zehn
stadtviertel ab seit vorgestern müssen
bereits die bewohner von elf anderen
vierteln zu hause bleiben nachdem das
virus sich dort offenbar vom wichtigsten
lebensmittelmarkt der stadt ausgebreitet
hatte nun werden alle arbeiter der
beiden märkte besucher und anwohner
getestet ein impfstoff gegen das virus
weltweit arbeiten biotech unternehmen
mit hochdruck daran in dem wettrennen
setzt die bundesregierung jetzt 300
millionen euro oft chorwerk mit so viel
geld beteiligt sich der bund an der
firma aus tübingen will dort aber
ausdrücklich keinen einfluss ausüben
nur die entwicklung des impfstoffs
beschleunigen heißt es offiziell
gleichzeitig aber stellt der
bundeswirtschaftsminister klar wir
verkaufen unser tafelsilber nicht
angeblich hatte us präsident donald
trump sich die forschungsergebnisse der
tübinger exklusiv sichern wollen die
bundesregierung will in diesem jahr so
viele neue schulden aufnehmen wie nie
zuvor insgesamt 200 18,5 milliarden euro
finanzminister olaf scholz plant mit
einem weiteren nachtragshaushalt um die
korona folgen abzufedern
um die dimensionen mal klar zu machen
schauen wir uns das jahren anfang des
jahres vor corona geplante die regierung
mit gesamtausgaben von 362
10 milliarden euro und einer schwarzen
null und jetzt also gut 218 milliarden
neue schulden
die neuverschuldung reist sowohl die eu
grenze als auch die im grundgesetz
vorgesehene der bundestag muss eine
ausnahme genehmigen florian hahn hat die
details schon vor monaten hatten sie
sich festgelegt dem abschwung alles
entgegenzusetzen was möglich ist
es ist die bazooka mit der wir das
notwendige er jetzt tun übersetzt rekord
kredite gegen jahrhundertkrise so plant
der finanzminister für 2020 weitere
schulden von 62,5 milliarden euro
zusätzlich zu bereits beschlossenen 156
milliarden ergebnis eine
rekordneuverschuldung von 218,5
milliarden was heute auch die ehemaligen
verteidiger der schwarzen null aus der
union gutheißen
schauen wir sehr stolz dass wir keine
neuen schulden gemacht haben aber ich
glaube diese corona krise ist eine
besondere herausforderung mit den
schulden will die regierung ihr
konjunkturpaket bezahlen etwa die
befristete senkung der mehrwertsteuer
die kredite bräuchten eine grenze findet
die fdp
die ausgaben seien falsch verteilt
meinen die grünen die bundesregierung
versäumt in diesem paket wirklich einen
starken impuls für klimaverträglichkeit
zu setzen und sie versäumt ist für die
ärmsten der gesellschaft zum beispiel
durch das anheben der regelsätze bei
hartz 4 für mehr gerechtigkeit zu sorgen
man meint solange ich heute neue kredite
bekommen bekomme ich sie auch morgen
irgendwann ist die grenze erreicht
tatsächlich muss deutschland an den
finanzmärkten derzeit keine zinsen
zahlen für frisches geld das dürfte auch
für die rekordschulden in diesem jahr
gelten
218 milliarden euro neue schulden das
ist fünfmal so viel wie im rekordjahr
der finanzkrise 2010 bezahlt wird die
rechnung von der jüngeren generation ab
2023 will mit der rückzahlung beginnen 8
milliarden pro jahr geld das dann an
anderer stelle fehlen wird erstmal muss
der bundestag die rekordverschuldung
noch genehmigen mit dem
nachtragshaushalt reißt die
bundesregierung schließlich die
schuldenbremse im grundgesetz
und jetzt in der sendung das
dauerproblem rexit klar ist seit februar
gehört großbritannien schon nicht mehr
zu retten
klar ist auch bis ende des jahres läuft
eine übergangsfrist
aber wie es danach weitergehen soll das
ist komplett offen und die gespräche
stocken um es vorsichtig zu sagen
heute haben die chefs die initiative
ergriffen grossbritanniens premier boris
johnson die eu-kommission chefin ursula
von der leyen ratspräsident scherrer
michelle und parlamentspräsident david
das soli haben sich in einer
videokonferenz zusammengeschaltet video
konferenz haben wir jetzt auch mit
brüssel und london zunächst an der green
egg in brüssel an er sieht sich die eu
da jetzt am längeren hebel also die eu
hat heute kühl zur kenntnis genommen
dass boris johnson gesagt hat er wolle
durchaus ein freihandelsabkommen mit der
europäischen union schließen allein mir
fehlt der glaube
hierauf brüsseler seite mehren sich die
zweifel dass die briten bereits sein
könnten das europäische angebot
anzunehmen weil es bedeuten würde dass
europäische standards auch noch eine
weile länger auf der britischen insel
gelten würden zb in der
lebensmittelindustrie die europäer
bleiben dabei denn tatsächlich sie sehen
sich am längeren hebel immerhin werden
45 prozent der britischen produktion
auf dem eu binnenmarkt verkauft während
umgekehrt die europäer nur zehn prozent
ihrer waren nach großbritannien
exportieren wie geht es jetzt weiter
die eu bereitet sich auf zwei szenarien
vor das eine ist dass im herbst unter
zeitdruck mit großem drama am ende doch
noch die briten bereit sein werden zu
einem mini handelsabkommen mit der
europäischen union europäischen union
das andere ist dass die briten ende
dezember endgültig aus der europäischen
union austreten ganz ohne vertrag geben
weiter nach london andreas stamm wie
hoch ist die wahrscheinlichkeit aus
britischer sicht dass das nichts mehr
wird mit einem abkommen
die gefahr ist durchaus groß keine frage
denn erstens johnson steht das wasser
bis zum hals r kämpft mit den folgen der
korona krise denn er muss die höchste
zahl an toten in europa verantworten und
auch die wirtschaft hat es im
europäischen vergleich mit am härtesten
getroffen selbst in den eigenen reihen
sagen kritiker das ist totales
regierungsversagen da ist der praxis
weit weg definitiv keine chefsache und
zweitens es gibt stimmen in dieser
regierung die sagen lasst uns doch zwei
rezessionen zum preis von einer haben
sprich die praxiskosten verstecken wir
einfach im schatten der viel größeren
corona krise das allerdings kann
eigentlich kein premierminister seinen
landsleuten zumuten sagt die vernunft
und selbst die briten sagen mit zwei
dritteln lasst uns diese übergangsphase
doch irgendwie verlängern das hat doch
nach corona alles keinen sinn mehr das
versteht doch jedes kind das klingt ein
bisschen nach sich wiederholende
geschichte im herbst könnte boris
johnson dann alles unterschreiben
diesmal um den status quo zu verlängern
dann kann man es anders nennen das wäre
gesichtswahrend aber es wäre eben nicht
wechselt wenn es nicht auch ein aber
gebe der boris johnson ist ein zocker
und die verzockten sich auch wir sind
gespannt wieder mal danke nach brüssel
und nach london und damit zurück zu uns
nach deutschland der gesamte
landesverband der afd in brandenburg ist
zu einem rechtsextremistischen
verdachtsfall erklärt wurden vom
brandenburger verfassungsschutz
es gehe dabei nicht allein um den formal
aufgelösten flügel und den bisherigen
landeschef andreas kalbitz sagen
verfassungsschützer und innenminister
sondern um viel mehr
die partei versuche die brandmauern der
demokratie zu schleifen jan meyer
berichtet aus potsdam
es war ihr bisher größter triumph bei
der landtagswahl im vergangenen jahr
holte die afg brandenburg über 23
prozent der stimmen
keine zehn monate später stuft der
verfassungsschutz den gesamten
landesverband als rechtsextrem 1
die brandenburger fdp hat sich seit
ihrer gründung stetig radikalisiert und
wird mittlerweile von bestrebungen
dominiert die ganz eindeutig gegen
unsere freiheitlich demokratische
grundordnung gerichtet sind
der rückhalt für den rechtsaußen andreas
kalbitz ist
trotz seines rauswurfs aus der partei
durch den bundesvorstand der einfluss
des volkes nationalistischen flügels ist
weiter ungebrochen
erst ende april dieses jahres für
aufgelöst erklärte flügel konnte und
kann in brandenburg aufgrund seiner
breiten basis und seines einflusses
praktisch nicht vom rest der partei
getrennt beobachtet werden nach dem
thüringer ist damit nun der zweite
landesverband der afg offiziell eine
rechtsextremistische verdachtsfall die
kritisiert die beobachtung durch den
verfassungsschutz als falsch ist für uns
ein erwartbares politisches manöver des
instrumentalisierten verfassungsschutzes
unserer partei die salamitaktik wirkt
man bedient jedes monat neues bundesland
was man unter verdachtsfall bestellen
möchte experten dagegen halten eine
beobachtung der gesamten afd durch den
verfassungsschutz für längst überfällig
der ft so geriert seit jahren sie sei
eine bürgerliche national konservative
kraft aber sie hat die
grundsatzentscheidung sich wirklich vom
rechtsextremismus zu distanzieren nie
vollzogen und das fällt jetzt auf die
füße
die brandenburger fdp kündigte am abend
an klage gegen die entscheidung des
verfassungsschutzes einzureichen wer
schweigt ist teil des problems und macht
sich mitschuldig dass wir die
verteidigungsministerien heute gesagt
annegret kramp karrenbauer mit blick auf
die eliteeinheit der bundeswehr ksk
nicht geschwiegen hatte ja ein hauptmann
in einem brief an die ministerin von
rechtsextremen tendenzen es dort die
rede
die beim kommando spezialkräfte geduldet
und teilweise wissentlich vertuscht
werden
armin coerper jetzt aus berlin sie
agieren im verborgenen möglichst
unsichtbar die soldaten des kommandos
spezialkräfte ksk nicht mehr zu
übersehen aber sei eine toxische
verbands kultur und eine art
kadavergehorsam im brief an die
verteidigungsministerin der dem zdf
vorliegt schreibt ein hauptmann der
eliteeinheit von einem nicht aus trocken
barren sumpf in dem brief heißt es
indizien rechtsextremer umtriebe werden
intern zwar wahrgenommen aber kollektiv
ignoriert oder gar toleriert und es
besteht die gefahr eines gehorsams
anspruchs der von kommandosoldaten in
ausbildung bereits mit dem der waffen-ss
verglichen wurde
rechtsextremismus haben der truppe
keinen platz so das
verteidigungsministerium hat sich
eindeutig positioniert dass sie es gut
findet dass diese mauer des schweigens
endlich auch ja durchbrochen wird der
syrische zeigt doch die elitetruppe ksk
kommt immer wieder in verruf mal geht es
um nazi lieder und hitler große zuletzt
um umsturzpläne in der kroner krise und
einen waffenfund im wohnhaus eines
elitesoldaten die linke fordert
konsequenzen
ich glaube nicht dass diese ksk einheit
reformierbar ist ich glaube sie ist von
grund auf durch sitzt von diesem
durchaus rechtsradikalen rechtsextremen
denken sie muss aufgelöst werden
die rechten umtriebe beim ksk untersucht
jetzt an den task force noch vor der
sommerpause will ministerin kramp
karrenbauer deren ergebnisse vorlegen so
und damit in der sendung gleich rüber
zum sport hier ist katja stresow ja es
hat wohl eine entscheidung beim tennis
gegeben denn die frage war finden die us
open statt ja oder nein bis eben was
offen nun berichten medien
übereinstimmend ja es wird ende august
in new york gespielt auch wenn sich die
tenniswelt in dieser frage
alles andere als eigentlich ist trotz
der entscheidung ist noch einiges offen
bei den us open
zb ob potenzielle teilnehmer die
sicherheitsmaßnahmen akzeptieren
denn die tennis-welt ist gespalten
zuschauer bei den adria oben dringen
sich als geber ist corona nicht
initiator und weltranglisten-erster
novak djokovic und alexander schwere
zurück auf dem platz
beide sind gegner der geplanten
maßnahmen bei den us open
wir sind dann sechs sieben wochen halt
so teil sozusagen im gefängnis also wir
dürfen wirklich nur aus dem hotel auf
die anlageform und anlage der zurück ins
hotel auf der anlage dürfen wir nicht
essen wir nicht duschen gehen dürfen wir
nichts machen und wir dürfen auch nur
eine person mitnehmen und bei
pressekonferenzen wohl auch nicht
derartig eng beieinander stehen
ganz andere sorgen plagen ashley partie
auch ich habe bedenken ich verstehe dass
die turniere unbedingt stattfinden
sollen aber die sicherheit aller muss
priorität haben die tennis welt ist
gespalten ob sie bei den us open
zusammen findet bleibt weiterhin offen
und zum basketball in der finalrunde um
die deutsche meisterschaft ist das
viertelfinale nun komplett die letzten
beiden plätze sicherten sich frankfurt
und bamberg die franken besiegten soeben
vechta souverän
der neunmalige meister aus bamberg in
weiß mit einem furiosen start in der
offensive kreativ und zielsicher bereits
nach wenigen minuten mehr als zehn
punkte die führung
vechta hat den oberfranken heute wenig
entgegenzusetzen nur selten sitzen die
würfe aus der distanz
der sieg der bamberger bleibt auch in
der zweiten hälfte ungefährdet am ende
ein souveränes 182 brose verdient im
viertelfinale gegen oldenburg und auch
frankfurt zieht durch fechters
niederlage in die runde der letzten acht
ein
die viertelfinals beginnen einer
mittwoch willkommen zurück hat ja beim
wetter kommt es sehr darauf an wo sie
wohnen im nordosten strahlt die sonne
bei sommerlicher wärme im südwesten
bleibt es grau und regnerisch mehr
gleich von katja honnefer dann empfehle
ich ihnen das heute schon mal mit der
kollegin marietta slomka 21 uhr 45
morgen gibt es wieder für heute sagen
wir alle danke für das interesse und ich
wünsche ihnen einen angenehmen abend
[Musik]
genau meine damen und herren das hier
ist eine konvergenz linie und die heißt
so weil ein tief im osten und ein tief
im westen zum einen trocken warme und
zum anderen feuchtwarme luft auf
kollisionskurs zueinander führen und
dann hat die luft gar keine andere
chance als aufzusteigen es entwickeln
sich dicke wolken und dann gibt es
kräftige regenfälle zum teil unwetter
und gewitter das war in den letzten
tagen so und bleibt auch in den nächsten
tagen so und jetzt gibt es noch
dauerregen am alpenrand in dieser nacht
im nordosten ist es dagegen klar und so
sinken die temperaturen zwischen
nordfriesland und der lüneburger heide
auf 809 grad sonst bleibt es bei 15 bis
10 grad bilder und morgen erwarten um
sommer- temperaturen zwischen der schlei
und der neiße werden 25 bis 27 grad
erreicht sonst liegen die werte meist um
20 grad am kühlsten aber ist es am
alpenrand mit nur 16 grad denn dort
regnet es noch am längsten weiter in der
gesamten südwesthälfte gibt es morgen
doch eher trüben himmel regenschauer
auch einzelne gewitter im nordosten
dagegen strahlt die sonne
diese konvergenz liebe zieht in den
nächsten tagen langsam weiter nach
nordosten bei den temperaturen ändert
sich wenig schönen abend noch